[Musique]
mon dieu tu tombes longue ton tour
dieu démarche
[Musique]
ça lui dire où je donne la la la la
magnifique m'a dit c'est qui
ça va vers l'arabe le manoir nicolas
[Musique]
je me les fantômes kelly bastien télé tu
vas être avec moi mais ce facteur a très
peur
[Musique]
on a quand même voulu aller au musée
quand même un petit peu de culture mais
voyant cette que aulas qui se termine
mais écoutez ce sera pour une prochaine
fois le musée un mois j'ai su protéger
mes oreilles et je vais rentrer chez moi
monsieur choi semences et avant même de
rentrer
[Musique]
voilà j'espère que vous avez bien aimé
l'émission sera présentée par matthieu
delormeau et elle est ravie d'y être je
faisais gros bisous et je vous dis à la
semaine prochaine tu as vu dans un état
semi était par terre à chaque fois
[Musique]